So, let us start the next portion, so please get ready, now in this segment we shall discuss
about the Topic Modeling Document Clustering, which is a very good example for using the
Jensen Library and the Latin Dirichlet Allocation.
So, what does it mean by Topic Modeling, so it is all about identifying the underlying
themes or topics within a collection of documents and whereas the document clustering is nothing
but the grouping of the documents, which is sharing the similar type of the themes of
the concepts as simple as that, so I repeat Topic Modeling is all about identifying the
underlying thing or the topic within a collection of documents, whereas the document clustering
is basically focusing on the grouping of the documents that share a similar context or
the themes.
Then what does it imply by the Latin Dirichlet Allocation or LDA, so it is basically a generative
statistical model, which we use for discovering the topics, which is a collection of the documents
and it assumes the documents are mixture of the topics, which is distributed over the
words.
Now, if we see the steps, which we are following here, first of all the pre-processing step
all of you know, under the pre-processing, what does we do, lower casing, tokenization,
removal of the stop parts, all those things will be performed and then dictionary and
the document term matrix, so it is created using the Gensim for covering the text data
into its numerical form and then LDA model, so a Latin Dirichlet Allocation, which is
trained with two topics and then finally the document clustering, so document clustering
with document similarity, is demonstrated using the cosine similarity between two documents,
so it will measure the cosine similarity.
So, let us start of the implementation one by one part, so all of you have this demo
NLP window, so let me just explain the part one by one and then all of you will execute
that answer and then we will at the end we will discuss about the outputs, which you
will see, topic discovered by LDA as well as the document similarity, how the document
similarity we are measuring or what are the concepts underlying it, that we will cover
up, so let us, before going the coding part, just a few concepts, which I want to discuss,
so already I have mentioned about the topic modeling, that we have discussed here at the
beginning LDA, fine, we have discussed of the Latin Dirichlet Allocation, we have discussed
of we have spoken about the document clustering and here in the notebook I am just showing
you the locations where you can go back and check the concepts while executing the code.
Here we will talk about the cosine similarity, now cosine similarity is a measure of how
similar to documents are based on the angle between their vector representation in a multi
dimensional space, which ranges between minus 1 to 1, so where plus 1 indicates the documents
that are identical in terms of their direction completely similar, 0 means the documents
are completely different, there is no similarity and the minus 1 that is suggesting the documents
are opposite meaning, so in cosine similarity there will be two document vectors and we
are trying to measure the angle representations in multi dimensional space, so their value
will range from minus 1 to plus 1, 0 from our commonsense you can understand they are
completely different, there is no similarity at all, minus 1 will suggest the documents
are completely opposite in terms of the meaning, plus 1 means they are identical, completely
similar, so as you can understand plus 1, if the plus 1 is completely similar, the more
we will go towards 1, the higher will be the document similarity, the more we will go towards
the 0, there will be very lesser similarity and at the 0 there will be no similarity, similarly
the more we will go closer to minus 1, the meanings will be opposite to each other and
at minus 1 exactly opposite meaning, so these are the part which we are going to cover up.
So, we have seen what is LDA, Latin Dirichlet allocation, we have seen document similarity,
we have spoken about the topic modeling and we also have seen the concept of the cosine
similarity, so these are the concepts now quite clear to you.
Now let us execute the coding part one by one, so first of all remember this is a very
important step, all of you those who are doing it, listen very carefully, go to run time,
click on the restart session, this click on the restart session, I will wait for a minute,
so those who are, I hope all of you are now ready, those who have come back from the break
now ready, those who are starting the session before implementing pip install Gensim, please
click on the restart session, either through control plus m or go to run time and then
click on the restart session, once you are done then you start executing one by one,
so pip install Gensim and then import the Gensim library which is a very much popular python
library is very much important for operations like topic modeling, cosine similarity calculations,
then from Gensim module, from Gensim import the corpora module for the smoother implementation
purpose, where you will get the lot of corpus informations and then from Gensim.models you
shall import the LDA model, so it will import the LDA class which will be very much used
for the calculations of the LDA related stuff, then we will take from nltk.corpus, we shall
import the stopwatch, so you will get all the stopwatch corpus which is present under the
nltk libraries or the tool, then what you will do, from nltk.tokenize, you will import
the word underscore tokenize, so you will get all the word underscore tokenize function
and from the nltk.
And then finally import nltk, so it will import the nltk library to access the other utilities
including the stopwatch, tokenization, lemmatization, all operations which you actually we do under
this and then from nltk.download, we shall download the punk tab, it will give the additional
support for the smoother execution of all those libraries.
And then download nltk.stopwatch, nltk.download we shall download all the punk tokenizer model
which are necessary for the tokenization operations and other relevant stuffs, then nltk.download
we shall download the stopwatch list which are very common words in English dictionary,
so that will be downloaded.
Then we shall take this sample, sample documents, so in the sample documents there are few words
sorry few sentences which we will take, so first sentence like for example artificial
intelligence is transforming the technology industry.
Second sentence what we are taking, machine learning and AI are shaping the future of
automation.
Third sentence, deep learning algorithms are a subset of machine learning.
Then fourth sentence, one term computing will revolutionize industries like AI and the fifth
one is healthcare is benefiting from AI and machine learning advances.
So these sentences we are keeping as the sample documents.
And then what we will do, we will pre-process the documents, so depth pre-process function
we are applying over doc and then stopwatch.words we shall apply over English and we will store
it under stopwatch and then what underscore tokenize doc.lower, so each of the document
basically we will convert them as already we have convert them in the lower case and
then we will basically tokenize them and we shall run basically word for word in tokens
if word.isalpha and not in stopwatch, that means those one are not in stopwatch that
will be return back as per our standard practice which we have just implemented during the
first chunk of the code which we implemented in the cell.
Then what we will do, we will apply the pre-process function over doc for doc in documents and
we will store under the pre-process docs and then what we will do, we will create a dictionary
and the document term matrix.
So what will happen in that case, so corpora.dictionary pre-process docs, we will apply the corpora.dictionary
function over pre-process docs and we will store it under the dictionary and dictionary
doc to doc to doc for doc in pre-process docs, we will store it under the doc term matrix.
So once this is done, then what we will do, we will train the LDA model.
So here during training the LDA model, we have to specify two topics.
So that is why LDA model function here doc term matrix will be the first function, number
of topics we shall keep as 2, id2 word will be dictionary and passes will be 15, that
means 15 iterations, the more we will give the iterations, it will give you the better
results.
Then print the topics with the associate words, print topics discovered by LDA, topics LDA
underscore model dot print topics, number of the words which are basically 5 top words
for each discover topic which we are going to print.
So for topic in topics, print topic, so it will iterate over the topics and print them
out one by one.
Then document similarity, so under the document similarity what we will do, dictionary doc
to doc we shall pre-process.
So two sentences here we will basically document take because already I have mentioned that
for the LDA cases we are taking two.
So for the quotient similarity, we will basically measure the similarity between two documents.
So that is why we are taking two.
So two documents, so one will be the basically whenever you will see the id as 0 for example,
like here if you see, one will be the topic id 0 and another will be the topic id 1.
Python is a zero indexing language.
So we will for these two documents which we will measure the quotient similarity, one
will be assigned as topic id 0, other will be assigned as topic id 1.
So now under this dictionary doc to doc pre-process, AI and machine learning are advancing rapidly,
doc to doc, dictionary doc to doc pre-process healthcare is benefiting from AI advances.
Then what we will do we will calculate the similarity with the help of the GenSIM, matutilis.cosim
where doc 1 bow and doc 2 bow will be taken and then this particular result has been stored
under similarity.
So we will finally print the result, document similarity, cosine similarity.
So in this way you will see these two outputs you will get, topic discovered by LDA and
then document similarity that means the cosine similarity with certain value.
We will interpret basically we will have to understand the interpretation of those results
that we will do, but first we implement this coding part, it is now 12.36, please complete
this step by 12.39 and while doing it remember this run, run time, go to run time, click
on the restart session first and then start it.
So by 12.39 please finish it up, 3 minutes will be grown up for implementing this part.
Thank you.
So hope all of you are doing it, I repeat for this particular segment before implementing
keep install GenSIM, click on restart session and then execute the entire part.
So just for the sake of understanding I am just telling you, these are the example cases
very important, they take similarity measurement, there are a lot of practical implementation.
Let me tell you for example I am not taking any name of the university, there are different
universities.
Nowadays for example those who have lot of affiliating colleges and it is a very much
time consuming task for the faculties to check the answer script.
So what they are doing, they are gradually implementing this type of the software and
few of them are quite active.
So what is happening for each of the questions, question paper faculties are setting up.
So there will be a sample text answer, so they are giving the sample text answer and
on the basis of the sample text answer what students are writing based on the text similarity
they are giving the software is giving them the mark.
So it is called the automatic evaluation of the answer script.
So that is what is happening in that case, it is actually removing the human errors during
the copy checking and most importantly timely delivery of the results which are very much
important that is also being implemented smoothly.
So faculties are setting up the question papers, they are giving a sample answer to each of
the questions and based on those sample answers the entire answer script is being evaluated
with the help of the software.
So these are the standard practice, it has a lot of practical implementations as well.
So there are many practical implementation of the NLP which we are to the topics which
are covering today.
Although I have explained in the entire thing, I tried to explain with the entire thing with
a lucid coding examples and simple examples but it has a lot of applications.
So today's topic is very much vital topic, those who are especially those who are implemented
in NLP and I have given you one interesting example related to the automatic evaluation
of the answers scripts and same thing similar type of the implementation also being made
during the checking of the plagiarisms.
For example if a certain research paper is present in online and some student or some
other researchers, if they dishonestly try to copy those concepts in their manuscript
that would be detected with the help of the certain plagiarism detector software.
So this is also being implemented here as well.
So remember that that is why I am telling these are the very important important part
of the execution of the NLP.
Even for example, people like me those who work in the AI application areas, for example
I apply in healthcare, just for example I am saying that I am applying in healthcare.
So you also use a lot of applications of NLP like for example the explanation generation.
So here they are also used in different line chain models that we learn gradually during
the upcoming sessions.
So for example if certain disease symptom is detected, for example we are doing certain
image analysis computer efficient related planning staff applications.
So we are doing image analysis and we have predicted one category of diseases and with
the help of the line chain model we are generating the corresponding explanation related to that
particular disease symptom.
If this is the particular grade of this disease then this precautions can be taken.
So this is as a holistically way it makes a very much lucid representation for the patients
with the help of the AI assistant that for this category of the diseases we have to take
this type of the precautions.
So these are the interesting implementations where AI can become the intelligent personal
assistant in the healthcare scenario as well.
So there are a lot of interesting applications in upcoming days.
The more you will go to the advanced level the more you will learn.
So anyway I believe it is now 1241 all of you have been able to implement this particular
part successfully.
So I am going back to the interpretation discussion.
So here basically here we will see some of the interesting cases topic ID 0 and topic
ID 1 because we have compared between two topic IDs.
So here as you can see in the output for example topic ID 0 left hand 0 implements the topic
ID 0.
So 0.112 into AI this is the weight associated with AI 0.065, 0.065, 0.065 and 0.065 which
is the weight associated with the topics like industries, quantum computing revolutionized.
So industries, quantum computing revolutionized they all these four cases it has received
the equal weights but highest weight which is associated with AI that is 0.112.
So in topic ID 0 we have seen that the highest weight the particular word AI has got the
highest weight, it has got the highest weight whereas 0.065, 0.065, 0.065 other topics for
industry, quantum computing revolutionized they have got the equal weight.
These are the words which has got the equal weight whereas AI the word got the highest
weight in a similar way if we see the topic ID 1 learning has the highest weight 0.129
whereas the other words like machine it has the associated with 0.092 but a subset 0.053
and also for the deep end algorithm they have the equal weights 0.053, 0.053 in this way.
So, the learning has got the highest weight, so in the topic ID 1 learning is the most
important word whereas in topic ID 0 AI is the most important word are you getting my
point so here the words associated with the highest word is the most important word in
the topic ID 0 where it is AI and in the second one it is learning.
In the second word you may say machine is the second most important topic as the associated
weight is the 0.092 whereas the subset deep end algorithm they have received the equal
weight 0.053, 0.053 and 0.053 in this way anyway so this is the part which we have discussed
now and the next part will be the document similarity so 0.288 if I say approximation
0.289 very much lesser similarity as we have learnt from the definitions of the cosine
similarity before execution of the code.
So cosine similarity if we see the score of the 0.289 approximately indicating the moderate
to low level of the similarity between these two documents.
This means the documents share some overlap in terms of the words or contents although
there are some overlap but they are actually completely different better to say technically
they are more different than similar.
So 0.289 implies the two topic ID which we have taken topic ID 0 and 1 they are more
different than the similar.
So this is what we are interpreting from the code this is what computer will interpret
from the code ok and from our basic sense from the visual understanding if we go back
and check can we can you check can you see AI and machine learning are advancing rapidly
healthcare is benefiting from AI advances from our view now we are interpreting from
our visual sense apart from the AI topic there is no similarity in the sentence.
So that is why there is a very lesser amount of the similarity that is 0.289 that is why
I mentioned that although a small portion are overlapping but they are mostly different
than the similar and that is why we got the result of the cosine similarity 0.289.
So as you can see it is clearly matching what we have given as the input your interpretation
output is beautifully matching with it ok fine.
I hope now it is quite understandable to all of you and you can see how AI is behaving
in a trust of the manner and giving away trust of the result.
So that is why this topic especially which we have covered so far all those topics are
very important and implementation angle this document clustering is very very important
topic modeling is very very important ok. So if I go back at the beginning where I have
mentioned that these 4 libraries which are very very important for NLP and gel we have
covered all those things we had covered NLTK at the beginning then we have spoken about
this Passy we have spoken about the text block and now we have spoken about NLC ok.
I think now it is clear to all of you ok. Now we shall implement we shall go for the
applications of the NLP we will see how NLP can be applied in the leadership angle.
So I am requesting our moderator to reshare this notebook link to all of you. This also
can be accessible from the demo 3 of the snippet.io but as I am not sharing it publicly because
it might happen that during the copy pasting you might change the course so that is why
it is not being shared rather you directly access it from the AI in leadership for the
research and making NLP applications ok.
And from my notebook also it is available but let me check actually in morning I found
that somehow it is not opening up. It is not opening up from my give somehow some problem
has happened I will check ok. So that is why those who are in my Github do not open the
AI leadership notebook ok because it is somehow not opening today. Some problem has happened
I will check ok. I will check and work upon it ok. So it was working yesterday night also
but today it is not working I will check it ok.
So that is why I have shared the notebook link with my moderator. This particular notebook
link you just implement one by one. So here we will see one of the very beautiful applications
ok of the AI in leadership decision making applications with the help of the NLP. Remember
I repeat and I request all of you that follow this one from the notebook do not go into
the repository of the AI in leadership ok. In Github it is not working I will check what
has happened and I have resolved it but the same code which is present in the Github I
have shared through this notebook ok. So just execute one by one just follow my instruction
and execute one by one ok.
So in this examples we will see that how we can use the python and hugging face transformers
ok for analyzing the sentiment of certain feedback comments and which can help the leadership
boards to make the decisions ok. So now step one first install the required libraries. So
here we shall pip install transformers. So transform module developed by hugging face
is a very much powerful library then what you do pip install torch ok. It is a core model
of the component of the python library which is widely used and then also the pip install
pandas. Pandas are very much powerful and versatile library for the data analysis and manipulation
purpose ok. So I repeat pip install transformer which is the transform module developed by
hugging face a powerful library then pip install torch ok which is torch module a very core
component of the python library and then pip install pandas which is a very much powerful
model and versatile library for the data analysis and data manipulation ok. So execute this
particular step of installing the required libraries then we shall move to the next step.
So it is now 1251 please finish this step by 1252 then we shall move ahead for the next
part portion of the discussion.
Thank you.
. I shall not repeat this. I shall not repeat this. I shall not repeat this. I shall
not for few more seconds and then move to the next step make sure that all of you are finishing
up. Well, so let us move to the next step. The next step what we shall do? We shall load
the pretend model now. So this pre loading of the pretend model sentiment analysis basically
which will do from the hugging face. So this pretend model will be loaded from the hugging
face. So from transformer import pipeline. So a pipeline is nothing but a hugging from
hugging face transformer ok. Then we shall load the pretend sentiment analysis pipeline.
So what we will do? Under the pipeline function we will take the sentiment analysis and we
will assign it as the sentiment analysis ok. So please complete this step of the second
part loading of the pretend model in the step 2. So it is now 1254 please finish this step
by 1255. So this is the second part loading of the pretend model. So this is the second,
this is the second part loading of the pretend model ok. So this is the second part loading
of the pretend model ok. So this is the second part loading of the pretend model ok. So
for few more seconds and then move to the next part please complete the loading of the
the p-tent models.
Now let us move to the next part, that is preparing the feedback data. So create a sample
data set of feedback comments. Now what we shall do here, we shall import the Pandas
SPD. Now you may remember during your Python classes, Mr. Behrer might have discussed with
you that to format dictionary value. So in Python dictionary value means key value pair.
So here you can see we have exactly from make a dictionary format. Data equals to you see
opening curly brace, then closing curly brace. Under that we have given some key value pairs.
Like employee is the key and their corresponding value. There are four values which we have
given, Amurto, Sangita, Faiz and Khudiram. These four names have been given there. Again
feedback and their corresponding value. So key value pair, we are forming in a dictionary
format in Python programming execution purpose. So here you see feedback colon under that
as per the standard provision of the dictionary format we are following. We are giving a third
bracket or the square bracket and under that four sentences. These four sentences are
associated with these four employee values. So here is the sentence, I love the new project
management tools, Sangita, the recent changes in the workflow are confusing. Faiz, great
team collaboration on the last project. Then Khudiram, I am not happy with the current
work environment. So these are the four input values which we are giving here. Then create
a data frame. We are forming a data frame. So pd.dataframe we shall apply over the data
as an input and storing it under the DF. So data frame has been formed. So first preparing
the feedback data is done. So just implement this part and let me know. So it is now 12.58.
Please complete this step by 1pm. In next two minutes kindly complete this step. Then we
shall move ahead for the next portion. So remember this dictionary data is containing
two keys, employee and feedback.
So this is the first part. So this is the first part. So this is the first part. So we will,
okay. So this is the first part. So this is the first part. So this is the first part.
I shall wait for few more seconds and then move to the next part. Please finish this
Now let us move to the next portion and that is basically the analyze the said statement.
So analyze the sentiment of each feedback. What we will do? We will basically make a
function to analyze the sentiment. So that is why the function name is analyze underscore
sentiment and feedback as an input we are taking. Then sentiment underscore analysis
function is applied over feedback and 0 where the most significant feedback has consisted.
We have taken care of and we are storing it under the result. So this 0th index has the
most significant information related to the sentiment and then return result level and
their result score level and their corresponding score is reprinted. So apply sentiment analysis
to this particular feedback column. So what we are taking the basically the DF feedback
and the DF confidence and we are storing it. Basically we are accessing the results from
the we are applying the zip function over a string DF feedback and apply the sentiment
analysis. So it will give you the output in a tabular format display the result. So here
it will give you will get the output of the tabular format where you can see the employee
name feedback and their corresponding sentiment will be printed and along with their confidence
value.
So as you can see employee I love new project management tool. This is the feedback. So
it is a sentiment is associated with it is a positive sentiment and the confidence score
is very high that is 0.949843. Then for example, so amorto has a zero index value and then
the first index is a so the recent changes in the workflow are confusing. It is a negative
comment, negative sentiment and it is to giving us the value of the 0.999406. Again you see
the feedback the great team collaboration on the last project sentiment is positive index
value 2 and there you can see the confidence value which we are getting that is 0.398871
Kodiram index value 3 because there are four names Python is a zero indexing language so
0123 this is how the labeling happened. Employee Kodiram I am not happy with the current work
environment, it is negative sentiment and you are getting the value 0.39772.
So as you can see I mean whether it is a positive or the negative sentiment the confidence
value score is very high. The more you will get nearby one that means the more confidence
level is more whether it is a positive sentiment or for the negative sentiment. So that is
why you can see I have added a note that a confidence score is a numerical value which
indicates how a certain machine learning model is about while making the prediction whether
it is a positive sentiment or negative sentiment this type of stuff. So if it is zero that
means there is no confidence if it is one that means it has a complete confidence.
So if its values very much closer to 0.95 that means the model is very much confident
about prediction but if it is 0.2 it is indicating a very low confidence about the prediction.
So here you can see all the values are like 0.39 something so whether it is a positive
sentiment or whether it is a negative sentiment the prediction has been made with the highest
nearby highest level of the confidence. 0.39 means almost nearby one that means with the
highest level of the confidence is there behind the prediction whether it is a positive sentiment
or whether it is a negative sentiment.
So please implement this particular cell and let me know regarding the analyzed sentiment
so it is 1.4 so please finish this step by 1.6 pm.
Thank you.
So not only it is about executing the code please check the output how the employee name
has appeared index wise the exactly the way we have defined here. So index value 0.123
in this way it has appeared their corresponding feedbacks are given there along with the sentence
sentiments has also appeared and with the highest level of the confidence prediction.
So as per our visual understanding also you can see it is exactly matching with the positive
sentiment or whether it is a negative sentiment as per the sentence from a visual understanding
and from our own cognizance we can understand it is matching and so we can see that how
the NLP algorithms are working very beautifully to give you the proper predictions proper
sentiment predictions as well as the proper confidence scores.
So this is how it is helping the leadership company leaderships leadership team to make
the decisions as per the feedback. So that is why this section with some demo value I
have given the name as the leadership that so all of you can get some idea that we have
learnt NLP and how to apply it. So apart from the topic modeling or document similarity
you can see how the sentiment analysis can help our leadership team to make a decision.
So I shall wait for few more seconds and then move to the next portion. So in the next portion
what we will do we will just make a group of the positive sentiment altogether and the
negative sentiment altogether. Here you can see all those things are appearing in under
a certain column but we can make the positive sentiment in one cluster and negative sentiment
in one cluster. So there will be a very simple line of course, couple of lines simple line
of course so where you can implement this particular steps.
So all of you have learnt about what is confidence score and how it plays a key role behind certain
predictions. Now here what we will do? We will make the example interpretation. So what
are we doing? We are basically creating a new data frame, one is for the positive feedback
and another one is for the negative feedback. So here you can see this for example this
particular segment cases. So it will contain a single row as you can see it will be a single
row and where you can see there will be the sentiment column. Single row with this particular
data frame is for the positive feedback and the next data frame is what we have done negative
feedback. So it will also have a single row of the sentiment with the negative feedback.
First one will have the single row with the sentiment value with the positive feedback
and the second one will have all the rows under the negative feedback column. So sorry
just a second let me zoom a bit otherwise you will not be able to see it.
So these two data frames are formed one for the positive feedback and another one for
the negative feedback. So in the first one we will have all the rows with under the column
of the positive feedback as you can see the sentiment value with the positive feedback
and the second one which we will form for the data frame for the negative feedback.
So there will be all rows which will come under the sentiment with the negative feedback.
So in both the cases all rows will come under the sentiment column one having with the positive
feedback value, another one will have with the negative feedback value. So please implement
this part.
So if you print the positive feedback and the negative feedback part, so as you can see
positive feedback value employ for example Amorto and Fyre with their index value 0 and
2. I love new project management tool and the great team collaboration on the last project.
These two are the feedbacks and their corresponding sentiments are positive and positive. So like
I mentioned that all row will come under a single column and where the sentiment value
are the positive and their confidence level 0.39483 and 0.871. So earlier case what happened
that we are getting them all together we have just separate them out by forming two data
frames with the positive feedback and negative feedback and they all the rows will come under
a single column of the sentiment, first one having the positive value and the second one
having the negative value.
And then also you can see the negative feedback employ Sangita and Khudiram with their corresponding
index value 1 and 3 and for example this same feedback negative and with their corresponding
confidence value is 0.39406 and 0.39772. So I believe that now all of you got some idea
that how AI can assist the leaders to make quick decisions in terms of the team gauging
of gauging the team sentiment analysis and through this analysis of the team sentiment
judgment purpose.
So accordingly they can make the necessary decisions in terms of the development. So
here we have seen the implementation right from the beginning installing of the required
libraries, here we have used transformer torch and pandas, then what we have done we have
implement the next particular portion, where we have done the loading of the pretend models
and then what we have done we have implemented the preparing the feedback data, where we
have for make the team take that have taken the key value pairs under the dictionary format.
We have stored under the data and we have created the data frame accordingly, then we
have analyzed the sentiments.
So basically we got the corresponding employees and they are sorry we got the employee names
and they are corresponding sentiment values and confidence scores, we have seen that confidence
scores are very high whether it is predicting the positive or the negative sentiments. Then
what we have done we have formed two different data frames, one for the positive feedback
another one for the negative feedback, where the all rows comes under the either the positive
sentiment value column or the negative sentiment value column.
So as you can see we have separated them out with according to different feedback cases,
one for the positive feedback cases, so this was for the output for the positive feedback
cases and the another one is for the negative feedback cases. So anyway, so just implement
this last portion of the code and then we shall conclude that concluded session. So
I have explained the entire part to all of you with my best efforts. So just implement
this part it is now 111 12 p.m. So complete this by 114 p.m. and I tried to give you enough
time to implement this course in your own space. I know that everybody will not have
the different typing speed or those who are copy pasting they please I also give them time
enough time to understand the each line of the code because as you can see the hash sign
each line interpretation is given there. So you can easily understand those things and
then also along with that all of you can check the output and try to interpret that whatever
the input is given accordingly whether you are getting the proper output or not.
So make sure that all of you are understanding the concepts which is very much important
and the reputation has another benefit that by mistakenly if I say something wrong during
the sleep of tongue or something like that I can rectify myself also. So that is another
benefit of repeating those things. If the instructor may have spoken something wrong
by sleep of tongue he or she can also rectify himself or herself. Anyway so please implement
this step and let me know that whether you are done or not. So I shall wait for few more
seconds and then we shall go to the question answering session. So moderators all good
participants are doing fine.
So these notebooks I have shared with TCSIM so please you can access the notebook from
your all of you know where to access the notebooks in your TCSIM portal. So I hope already they
whether either they have already loaded there or they will share their shown. So please go
there and access them and already you might have download we basically you download it
from my GitHub also but today one particular notebook like this one we are unable to access
it from GitHub from my GitHub so I will check the issue.
But earlier one the first one in LP it is already there and notebook links are also shared with
you so you can directly access those things I hope all of you are accessing. So apart
from going to the TCSIM portal you can do it by yourself as well because already both
of the notebooks are shared with you and also remember I have shared one important information
related to the sleeper.io. Although I have not shared the links as I told you that once
you it is a very good platform for sharing the course with the learners but if you make
mistake if any single candidate make mistake by copy pasting it or make certain changes
in the code unintentionally it will affect others. So that is why I have not shared it
but I just mentioned that sleeper.io is a very good tool for sharing the course.
Anyway so I think let us take a couple of minutes break and then we shall go come back
to the question answering session. So there is a break of 2 minutes.